elle a pas de pop
on a fait je ne crois pas que ce soit
alcoolique a en france
oui auprès du vin c'est un fait mais ça
veut pas dire qu'on soit un acolyte le
problème la france ne tient pas sur le
même graphique que les autres pays en
1965 sur cent mille personnes
l'alcool tué douze français pour un
allemand la drogue c'est pour moi c'est
un danger public c'est plus pire que
l'album
sondage exclusif fief de publi mettrie
69% des français pensent que l'alcool
est une drogue 27% pensent le contraire
et 5% n'ont pas d'opinion et liane foly
qui vivent très vieux gagné il ya des
presque centenaire puisque la drogue ça
vous tue tout ça bout du scan fatalement
ça bout tu lire plus d'hommes à ya pas
de comparaison un alcoolique on peut
encore les guérir tandis qu'à 1 1 3e
j'en ai jamais vu en france il y a six
mille drogué pour 4 millions alcoolique
la maison du café mais sitôt sorti de la
maison
le premier bistrot qu'il ya je commence
au moulin alors à nanard mon travail
c'est tout bistrot alors c'est dublin
dublin et pas des petits des ballons et
j'en arrive où j'arrive à en voir
huit mois ça va on arrive à monter avant
d'arriver à mon travail et après je pars
au rouge
oui le vert c'est vraiment pas de
l'alcool c'est une nourriture ses envies
le vin non c'est pas d'alcool c'est ça
fait du bien le bain 4 litres de vin à
12° égal 1 litre d'alcool pur à 48
degrés le vin c'est aussi pour la france
une civilisation une culture un prestige
et une source appréciable de revenus
pour 1972 par exemple la france a
exporté pour près de 419 milliards
d'anciens francs de vins et spiritueux
[Musique]
en france on a tellement d'occasions de
voir que ce soit y pour une naissance
pour un enterrement ou quoi que ce soit
y vous allécher les enfers du travail
bon la première chose qu'on vous dit
vous voulez boire un coup bon bah y'a
messieurs aura messieurs en 1970 mort
par la route 15 1034 personnes mort par
l'alcool 30000 478 personnes soit plus
du double j'ai commencé à boire quand
j'étais jeune parce que je me suis
mariée jeune et après j'en ai pris
l'habitude du bébé en famille comme tout
le monde peut-être et puis je me suis
servi comme comme stimulant comme c'est
devenu une catastrophe mais pensez qu'il
ya 600 milles française qui boivent et
en somme on ne sait pas parce qu'une
française elle boit elle se cache elle
c'est pas comme un homme elle a honte
alors elle bouge chez elle et c'est très
dur a décelé une femme qui boit ça c'est
la france
une bonne bouteille mais
il ya toujours une bonne bouteille sur
la table ça c'est évident je ne pense
pas qu on est alcoolique c'est pas pour
ça qu'on est alcoolique bio france ô
beaux gosses d'alcool puisque cet enfant
ce que dirait qu'on boit plus d'alcool
dans le monde mais à 70 %
il s'agit du vin la bière viennent
ensuite en troisième lieu vous avez des
apéritifs notamment les spiritueux a
visé et ensuite les autres villes parmi
lesquelles le risque ya une petite place
cinq ans environ de la consommation
globale française et qui doivent à tout
le monde de toutes les classes de la
société boivent et on assiste
aujourd'hui même à l'altruisme des
cadres qui devient de jour en jour plus
alarmant est pourquoi boissons gazeuses
les médias us vous avez la publicité
d'une part d'autre part vous avez un
certain nombre de gens qui boivent qui
sont mal à l'aise dans leur peau et qui
sont victimes d'une maladie de
l'adaptation façade vie est trop dure
surtout dans les concentrations urbaines
les jeunes jambes un peu les jeunes gens
on a cru il ya quinze ans des jeunes
buvaient plus d'alcool
en réalité ils se remettent à boire
seulement ils boivent plus comme le
devanciers il ya aussi que les boissons
alcooliques ou de sous enchère ils sont
frappés de deux textes moindre que du
coup les boissons non alcooliques des
lunes des jus de fruits de ces dommages
c'est là qu'il faudrait une action
gouvernementale pas un gouvernement n'a
osé prendre ces mesures alors quel est
celui qui osera en conseil des ministres
en belgique et que tout le monde connaît
la question reste ouverte
[Musique]
chaque année l'alcoolisme couteau
français 7 milliards 500 millions de
nouveaux francs en france dit on tout
finit toujours par des chansons et ses
refrains bachique parviennent encore en
fin de banquet à donner bonne conscience
aux français qui pourtant avec 26 litres
d'alcool pur par adulte et par an
détient le record mondial de
consommation
[Musique]